quand on va voir un match de foot on ne
se pose pas la question de la domination
politique quand on est sous l'emprise
d'une drogue ou quand on regarde un film
porno on se pose pas la question de la
domination politique et la Boétie montre
bien que cette stratégie a un double
intérêt car en plus de détourner
l'attention du peuple de sa servitude
elle induit ce qu'il appelle un
abolissement de la volonté
l'accoutumance au divertissement nous
fait perdre le goût de notre liberté et
donc cette stratégie d'amollissement de
la volonté par le divertissement montre
bien que le pouvoir ne s'exerce pas
uniquement par la force car lorsqu'il
s'exerce par la force le pouvoir devient
visible le pouvoir ne s'exerce pas
uniquement par la force il s'exerce
d'abord par la ruse et le divertissement
c'est la ruse du pouvoir pour produire
un amollissement de la volonté et un
abrutissement de l'esprit on rend les
individus consentants et donc acteurs de
leur soumission
un peuple diverti est un peuple
consentant